greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happening now is brought to you
by on it don't forget we're still
running the contest till January with
alpha brain registered order the alpha
brain get it get the lottery ticket
you're automatically in the contest
which is the honored experience two days
$1,000 cash product all that stuff go to
Anna calm right now look at the great
selection of supplements if you see
something you like pressing Church on
the way out and get 10% off delivered
right to your crib we're also sponsored
by CBP Lyon the best when it comes to
CBD I live off the tension I'm an old
man I take two shots an hour before I go
to bed and it's not be new no time no
peeing no nothing go to CBD line right
now and get that second party lab
results for yourself this isn't no gas
station CBD this is CBD lion calm go
right now and enter code church and get
20% off delivered to your house and it's
also its ones there right I don't know
how to tell you this tomorrow you got
two big games or one big game you got
the NBA
you got Diaz versus Myles Duvall this
week and if you're gonna make money this
is the week of the mix of money alright
go to my bookie Dynegy they're not
playing any games over there if you're
trying to bet NFL baseball I'm in May
whatever my bookies got alright they're
running a super contest I've told you
this a thousand times
it's 100 to anything you pick five teams
a week they cover the spread and you get
points first place on $1,000 where you
gonna get that action from nowhere
[ __ ] so do me a favor right now
today double your first deposit use
promo code Church grab a pen CH you are
CH to get a hundred percent bonus on
your initial deposit up to a thousand
dollars Joey what does that mean what
does that mean if you put in a nickel
they're gonna give you a nickel [ __ ] oh
and that's how it starts so visit my
bookie got it
AG today that's my bookie my Bo okay ie
da AG and don't for use to use promo
code Church when creating your account
kick this [ __ ] melee but Megu slobs
you sit in my eyes get all teary I go
back to [ __ ] 1980 you understand me
first time I saw how are you mister very
well thank you and thank you very much
of thank you for inviting me to your
show man you do some great work I always
tell people that anybody could be a
[ __ ] friend when you're alive to have
a friend when you're dead that's special
somebody to look after you somebody to
keep your name alive somebody to keep
your work alive and you've done a great
job a try that's my job to keep Brian's
music and his legend alive I know he I
promised him that before he passed away
and do what I can and there's also to
try and read this horrible disease which
one day hopefully we'll find a cure ah
they found that in Mexico I don't know
what's going on here you go to Mexico
they freeze your ass holding you back
jumping up and down here knows nothing
these white people know nothing
you got a Mexico they [ __ ] kill you
only Steve McQueen didn't get [ __ ]
killin everybody else later but I have a
friend that suffering he went down a it
was a procedure they won't do here
stem cells nobody went to Mexico they
froze the cancer boom I just lost too
much FDA things they have to be approved
before you can get something going and a
lot of times you know some of the
pharmaceutical companies maybe they
don't want to find a cure if they make
too much money but you know I remember
one I went to get when Ronnie was first
on his chemo and there was a pill I had
to go by and she said that was $600 and
said we have insurance she does know
that's the copay which is okay for us
but what about Joe bro down the street
$600 a pill that you have to take every
month I mean forget it and that's just
the beginning of I mean yeah if we could
sit here for hours and talk about all
the things and faults in the medical
system yeah there's always a by the way
yeah my friend's mom broke her hip last
week and they could hospital in Santa
Monica the lights went out no the mold
was on the wall Santa Monica in the ER
they had to close the hospital so they
had taken the Torrence she's there with
her mother and I mean this chicks a
[ __ ] daycare teacher they come in
would have built good for transporting
to that because Medicaid only
I was 21 [ __ ] miles really wouldn't
you come up with that number for 21
miles so they wanted like eighty two
dollars a mile and it was like an
additional eight miles
this lady Bailey you know she they kept
teacher but this is our system these are
the by the ways you find out yeah when
you get sick we never think about
getting same just pay sure exactly and
then one day you're in the hospital you
like what the [ __ ] do I pay for yeah
yeah
oh it doesn't cover aspirin at 2250 or
[ __ ] that you know I thought my wife
to bring up your ass so it's it's uh
it's it's you know you have to take care
of yourself you do you don't have to be
healthy what you did you meet Ronnie I
met Ronnie in brown I think was 1974 Wow
and when did you finally go a couple of
them like you have friends for a while
right we never broke up you always oh I
thought you wouldn't I think you wanted
a friend for a while things that go on
in life and as you know as ups and
there's downs and we went through ups
and downs yes we did but we were 74 and
1974 he was just he had just completed
the first rainbow album Ritchie
Blackmore's rainbow and they were they
were had not been on the road yet they'd
not toward yet but they've completed the
album I met him at the rainbow and
sunset and we started going out together
and then he went on the road and he
called me and said quit your job come on
the road I said no I can't quit my job
when I come for a couple of weeks I
never went back he was rich at the time
ya know the first time I ever ever even
heard of Ronnie James Dio was rainbow
rising uh-huh Wow
and they did a show maybe 79 78 with the
scorpions
yeah yeah okay yeah I think sheckman
showed up in Jersey it was a [ __ ]
party yeah and I went down there and at
the time I'm not gonna lie I went down
for Ritchie Blackmore's I want another
for the scorpions but Ronnie James
impressed me like that I went home and
bought the album and stargazer oh yeah
oh that's fabulous that song is is one
of my very favorites it's moralist I'm
Oliver I'm the same page so I took it
home and pop up a pop up a pop and you
know Ronnie James Dio whatever then [ __ ]
or replaces his singers he came in with
another [ __ ] guy with a rock you all
my long remember that - sure and then
you know I fell into Black Sabbath by
mistake you know I hate sorry Ronnie
yeah I put on war pigs like everybody
else
mm-hmm maybe 13 almost jumped out of
[ __ ] window you know that was it and
then I bought like sabotage and I was
ready to [ __ ] go where's the heroine
like where's the [ __ ] heroin and the
mashugana pills we need it all and then
I blinded my book master reality and
I've got angel dust and snorted the
angel investor it was like my birthday
it was my 17th birthday I bought master
reality and The Exorcist was on oh and I
had the exorcism with master reality
over it with earphones on tripping on
this [ __ ] angel dust and I shut it
down I never listened to master reality
so I was a big Ozzy and then my mother
died and Sabbat bloody Sabbath was the
theme that was my new avenge - [ __ ] on
the world I gotta take him my mother and
then I went to see Black Sabbath and
they were [ __ ] god-awful with Van
Halen Van Halen took him to do you know
Van Halen was the opening act nobody
went to see the opening activity in the
70s you had to 8:30 to get there you
know nobody went to the open act but the
word on the street was to go catch this
van Halen band and they came out like
[ __ ] they ran the garden and I still
number watching Bill Ward snorting coke
off the snare drum
like we were sitting that close they
were that [ __ ] up and you could tell
and then Circus magazine which I still
have a copy thereof
you know Black Sabbath left you know and
they first they got this Cigna they
carry brown something Brown have you
ever heard no the Black Sabbath videos
with him before Ronnie James Dio no it's
[ __ ] god-awful
no it's god-awful Dave something from
the bank called Savoy Brown joining the
Sabbath temporary three songs all
horrible and then Ronnie James Dio sand
snip them and people were like he's the
guy from rainbow but you're [ __ ]
filling into Joe Montana shoes mm-hmm
yeah totally amazing yeah you're filling
in what Ronnie James Dio had a pull-off
was a [ __ ] magic trick and the album
came out yeah we wanted to [ __ ] hate
it everybody was looking I hate that
[ __ ] out you know [ __ ] him La Paz E
and every song heaven how are you like
Jesus children the see Jesus died young
Jesus you know I want to hate this
[ __ ] song but I like it and then he
did a tour you're gonna see I'm not
[ __ ] yeah you have a boy and they
played Philadelphia it was Black Sabbath
with Ronnie James Dio
[ __ ] off from Sammy Hagar with shakin
Street and it was raw
Montrose Robbie without [ __ ] not
Philadelphia now let me tell you
something I don't know if you know how
concerts work but if you look at a tour
the first two nights they always touch
on Philly do you know why to get it out
of the way yeah they're savages they
just want to get it out of the way in
their worst condition they don't even
want to go to Philly at the end of the
tour when they're that much strong
they're like I saw ac/dc August 4th 1979
which Bon Scott then Bondi Navy he was
replaced by whatever and that
[ __ ] had tough shoes to fill but
the Osborne shoes and you had a film in
Philadelphia where they don't [ __ ]
around and they were taking Sammy Hagar
Philip thought I was in six row on a
hill and like [ __ ] acid in the
Philadelphia they were spitting on their
fingers and flinging that Sammy Hagar
their animals you gotta remember that
was the only stadium that had a
courtroom downstairs one of Ronnie's
favorite places to claim we recorded
he's one of his favorite cities it's
crazy like I got a casino there I know
it's totally hate so much they knew you
yeah he's like he's a working-class guy
that says hey you know what you don't
mess with me I'm here whether you like
your Nam yeah and he wasn't the tall guy
now he wasn't a big guy know that sure
he went out to Philadelphia and he came
out with his [ __ ] malocchio horns was
from his Italian [ __ ] heritage yeah
and you know just he won him over and I
still remember people having signs
saying like go [ __ ] yourself they're not
gonna say you know the City of Brotherly
Love kind of previous that's [ __ ] in
Philadelphia you better bring every
bullet you got you know and one song
after the other and then he started
doing Sabbath's
yeah yeah Nativity in black or something
we'd like okay like it's one thing to do
your songs at Tony Iommi but now you're
dipping into [ __ ] not now you're
causing problems right now we're gonna
have past you leave feeling the same
like now we're gonna attach the leave he
started singing Sabbath songs and one by
one he was winning the Mogul then they
left cuz he sang him his own is always
trying to be on no never try to be
honest a generals got it no masses no no
no like he was into it he was selling it
little by little and then I caught him
maybe eight months later on the return
but this time I think I think it was the
Nassau Coliseum I'm not sure
mind is all over the place I was trying
to beat myself up to get this and he was
[ __ ] phenomenal like everybody left
they're like who's Isaac like we don't
give a [ __ ] that's different I always
say it's a apples and oranges you know
Ozzy was an innovator in the Black
Sabbath a heavy metal music and he was a
great showman a great showman
and he was great with the songs the way
they sang them the way they performed
them ronnie was completely different
ronnie was a different thing it was more
of a melodic singer and took him to a
different place but I still see I think
that you can be an Aussie fan and a
Ronnie fan and appreciate both but
you're looking at yeah yeah you're
looking yeah and it's so weird that I
had a phobia when I first started Tommy
I would look behind the curtain if I'd
see people with white hair
I would [ __ ] my pants and I would try to
adjust my material and I would fail
miserably
and this is why you asked me before the
show if I would ever be interested I
thought yeah this is my opening joke
right now I just got a call from a
daycare and they said would you do the
reverence stand up and I go can I talk
to your daughter please cuz their
daughters like 23 and she on the phone I
listen I love you went out with my
opening joke right now it's when a gay
guy who feeds his victims hot dogs to
get him ready for dick they don't want
to open you don't want to open with that
joke at a Christian organization
so I would look lying the curtain and I
was such a [ __ ] you know till this day
I take two
I take one 0.25 xanax and put it in my
pocket it's an oval little [ __ ]
Alex's they don't even do nothin to it
because of the anxiety I get before I go
onstage especially when I get to the
Comedy Store that little first 10
minutes well then when that light turns
blue and I'm next my whole world changes
and how I get myself to this stage it's
by thinking about you
yeah that's not what it is you know how
he used to get already faster have a
fight with me yeah no see I used this
for me yeah for me to be really good on
stage I need to get into an argument
summary and he'd have people that
aggravate me like with you a go at me
before I go on stage and you have to
follow me you don't have a hard time
what's aggravating me means anything you
do yeah well I'm not greenroom don't do
nothing I don't wanna hear but don't
move don't get up don't get up that's
why I stopped smoking cocoa people
because they moved around a lot
don't get up sit right there where you
going sit down you don't see what's out
the window oh it's another day with you
I'm one of those people so I like to get
aggravated a little bit before I go on
stage like somebody to aggravate me for
me to go off on somebody they have to
know me like if I'm with Wendy I know
Wendy what the [ __ ] you know you know
and then one because he's just going on
stage watch when he gets off and then
when people get used to it but you have
to get fired up so for me for the last
20 years whenever I have a doubt
I go [ __ ] it out of respect for Ronnie
it was dear to myself as I welcome to
the stage myself because he did
something that nobody saw I didn't see
it and then it would alleviated the pain
was he did such a great job
yeah with Sabbath in the album and the
tour and then Ozzy did a great job
yeah with blizzard and nullify their way
exactly
everybody stood their ground yeah can I
ask you a personal question
is there any animosity between heaven
AHA see I've never heard no I no not at
all I mean I think that even myself like
if I was being how was to leave like
Sabbath
and somebody would come in I think for
the first year my ego would be fractured
but after I listened to the work and
listen to what the man did I think I
mean we saw him quite often in the
rainbow or different places
hi how you doing what's going on I mean
they weren't great friends but they were
always very polite very nice to each
other yeah always that's great
no but that's uh you know I went all
away to 83 Ronnie when he had Vivian
Campbell mm-hmm on the Holy Diver then
after that quaaludes coke and a little
time I lost contact you lose contact
when you go to prison why they wouldn't
write back no that I mean I was you know
after 83 I just wasn't the [ __ ] drugs
and stabbing people and [ __ ] I didn't
get a grip of my life we get into like
1990 by that time you know I don't even
know about the human eyes yeah like a
friend of ours turned me on to a very
underrated album and it's [ __ ] it's a
great album you know why because it came
out in the 90s and right when grunge it
so everybody was now listening to grunge
and it was not so it's been actually we
are re releasing that very soon yeah
yeah next year so he only did not
correct me if I so he only did I mean
help to humanize now one of the hardwood
Sabbath heaven and hell' mob rules
mob rules I'm sorry a live a live album
caught on stage or something I forget
what it was called you've all his then
yeah evil something evil and then he
went back to do to human a did you see
humanize her in the 90s and then he went
back just before he passed away and they
did the devil you know and but that was
a car mine own only a piece really any
bill would still me no bill they wanted
to go back this last time with bill but
bill had had some health problems
yeah so he he didn't couldn't do it and
so we got Vinny back again
I guess he's okay now yeah he's doing
great I heard that bill cause he was
like hold on yeah
no sir that was the last Sabbath tool
but that was without bill yeah now we're
doing another one Sharon said get back
on that [ __ ] yeah yeah so now
there's another
with bill that's great news that's great
that's a friend of mine just brought me
he signed this snare for me uh-huh
you know so that was all my time I loved
all that [ __ ] I loved but that's the
honest-to-god truth that's Ronnie James
Dio his legacy to me is one he didn't
philadelphi like he just [ __ ] made me
a believer like and I guess I would
never I was no rude I would never gonna
throw anything Oh some people did but
Philadelphia I'm telling you there was
spitting off their [ __ ] things I
remember Sammy Hagar ducking like I
still remember Sammy hey Ronnie wouldn't
[ __ ] you yeah and he right in somebody's
face no he was not afraid of because
don't forget he'd work for years and
years in elf and before that all the
bands he'd been in bands since he was 10
years old even in places where weddings
where drunks would come off and they'd
get off the stage all this I mean he
knew how to exactly how to deal with an
audience because for so many years so
many years
well it's hysterical because he I don't
know you were there you know the
lifestyle and eighties and what was
going on we lived in northern New Jersey
know how to drive to Philadelphia so I
drove down there with this kid that he's
got now arrest his piece great kid one
of my brothers and we stopped at a
Burger King him to Pete and he comes on
he goes you're not gonna believe this
there's a guy in there and he's sellin
acid all right so we're like we need
acid for this we add acid but we'll take
more what's he got and he had these
purple hits they were MicroBot acid Mike
without acid was very tiny purple these
things were like a marshmallow a little
marshmallow but they were purple so I
said I'm good I got my acid we have like
windowpane or whatever the [ __ ] he took
his acid we get to the Philadelphia
concert we're outside tailgating it's
[ __ ] Philadelphia what's not called
we're doing acid whatever the [ __ ] we're
doing
he comes up to me this kidney or she not
gonna believe it but this kid doesn't
like his tickets he wants to trade him
for some money so we have like nine
throw and we traded for sixth row and
like ten bucks so here we are six rows
Santa will let us see Ronnie James Dio
everything's fine it's four of us but we
had to split up into two and two so I'm
with this lunatic that got the
marshmallow marshmallow purple acid and
you know shake and streak those up but
whatever goes up Ronnie James Dio the
place blows up Sabbath I look down he's
[ __ ] past that I mean past I had to
pick him up put him on his chair you
know you said that the concerts over too
long cause he's a bodybuilding [ __ ]
huge I gotta pick him up we bring him to
the car we sit him down we drive him
back north he's still the next days like
what's up man
so ever since that night we see him we
go with chipper to break his boss he's
very sensitive we go you didn't do
[ __ ] acid you did purple quaaludes
cuz they put him out and he kept saying
I didn't do purple quaaludes I mean till
the day he died
he would say something like we gotta go
out on 31st Street and pick up like
listen great coke I don't 35th and I
would go you didn't think I'm quietly
have you seen the trailer for the
rainbow I was there I was at the
premiere well a minute you're in it yeah
I [ __ ] do it when do you like [ __ ]
you're everywhere at the time I was how
really wasn't it was it was amazing it
was a time that would never come again
you do drugs with me no never no no
because I smoked the only time when I
was clean yeah or her life yeah when I
was about 16 somebody gave me in England
hash but I don't know what was in it but
whatever was in it I threw up for three
days and I was sick us anything it so I
never touched it
drink I know I can get drunk fall down
I'll wake up's over the next day but
that was I don't want it I never touched
anything I went to all the parties that
everybody was doing some what they all
know I didn't do it so I didn't how was
it down there oh it was well the record
labels used to pay for everything in
those days Zeppelin will come in town
they put the big thing in between the
two tables all a Zeppelin be there you'd
have to whoo there you'd have deep
purple everybody could possibly think of
was there it was amazing time amazing
time I chased Keith Moon down the road
one time because he didn't pay his bill
and drugged him by the back of the neck
you there for that [ __ ] oh yeah that's
why I met Ronnie that was last time you
seen Richie Blackhawk well I haven't
seen Richie and my goodness 20 years
not for nothing no disrespect thank God
holy [ __ ] he's gonna be popular Thursday
night have you seen him lately
no have you seen when he looks like yeah
holy [ __ ]
it is no boy bad it's not good he looks
like some he looks like a character like
that like a Halloween character and he
doesn't tour with those guys no more I
can do his own thing yeah cuz Joel and
Turner's from my neighborhood Joe is a
good friend of mine nice guy nice guy
I know him since he was in the other bed
before rainbow did a great job in
rainbow too different as he said that
different again it was different
different into Ronnie rainbow and there
was a Joe Lynn toy and I think you did a
great and grand bargain I think they all
did a great job
grandpa it was kind of funky I like I
like Joe in more than Graham bonnet I
used to manage a Grammy now what a [ __ ]
is great how could they surround is
around where he's around now where did
he go after a rainbow I'll purchase
Alcatraz that I managed for a while
Jesus Christ
what I thought he was like in he sounds
although uh he sounds a lot like that
other band from SIA
so I thought he was in that band but I
don't even know what the [ __ ] bags
like he's a good guy I saw him I think
lost my saw him was at the Greek he had
gone to see I think deep purple yeah you
weren't all this [ __ ] oh yeah yes sir
all yep what was dioz happiest times oh
it was Ronnie he's like Sabbath Sabbath
well he was duelin holy died I mean
Vivian camp were a lot of different
times but his favorite band was Sabbath
really I think and I was really glad
that he got to reunite with the band and
do that last album and the tour cuz they
all loved each other and everything and
they were playing amazing I mean you'd
never know that ronnie was sick he was
amazing to the loss no and I think that
Ronnie could never have lost his voice
or grown old so that's the only thing I
say about him dying when he did was he
died on a high note that's a beautiful
thing you just said no it's funny
because when I opened up with the human
eyes I saw look in your eye and yeah I
had that same feeling oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's been gone nine years now
it'll be ten years and all that [ __ ]
we're gonna have a big [ __ ] party yeah
we really don't know six months yeah
yeah we already know weeks from there
with you only to 2020 so February 20th
21 days the 19th oh and it said the will
to note the world
yeah I don't know I don't know yeah yeah
please February 29th and Valentine's Day
yeah yeah what's that event which event
just one to twenty oh we're doing a big
gala
we're gonna have I will do some in the
hologram we'll do some other bands
we'll have an award show of people that
I want to award who've been in Ronnie's
life mostly industry people but
presented by a celebrity I thought that
would be fun and also we'll have tables
I think it's 35 tables downstairs and
then it's like a thousand people
upstairs and
the fans were only going to charge $25
because I Ronnie would want to give back
to his fans as he always did so we want
to have really cheap tickets for the
kids and then the industry could pay for
[Laughter]
more than God it's raising money for
cancer yes yeah it goes yeah yes yeah
yeah what it's all about yeah you're
doing is a beautiful thing
I mean you you're doing God's work
you're doing your killing two birds with
one stone i wish i had the patience i
love to do keeping others oh yeah
exactly if we can save just one person
by you know saying only detection saves
lives you know women are good about that
and check men no you drag them down
there no I get that
well we're working we're working right
now with dr. wall at UCLA we've been
supporting him and paying for them
and they are developing a swab test so
instead of having the finger up the bum
that you have a swab test and that's for
pancreatic cancer colon cancer and
gastric parents's stomach cancer and
that should be out by next year so you
could go and you have swab taken at your
local GP they send it away it comes back
really really early detection if you
have any one of those cats as obviously
you have to then go on through other
testings but it's a breakthrough and
we're really excited about some of the
stuff that you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
we've been supporting him for the last
two years and and we're paying for all
this medical team to do this where's
there a web page of people who don't do
cancer fund org that's it that's it and
it's run by you it's well 14 board
members what do we have fourteen bombers
she does one of them we have a doctor we
have two lawyers we have a trucking
company of biggest trucking company
there is up stage in there when are
there directors they have a sound
company lining company other managers
two other managers PR person we're in
hell
and what do you guys decide on where the
money's going to be spent yeah yeah yeah
we always make sure that it doesn't go
into an administration or fat cats
pocket because we don't know why we
formed that's we watch every single
penny where it goes and we we've given
like we gave a Vanderbilt in Nashville
we gave them a hundred thousand for
stomach cancer they had no research
money whatsoever for stomach cancers and
so because we gave them a hundred
thousand someone else gave him five
hundred thousand and then the government
got a grant for 11 million so a lot of
times houses seed money we put it into
places where they don't have a research
team for that or now we're working very
closely dr. Wong we know exactly every
penny goes you know one day we had a
conversation a couple weeks ago that
like anybody else
you you catch a break and you want to
help yeah you know you want to help
there's nothing worse than helping
somebody when you know you feel like
you've been [ __ ] oh I've been [ __ ]
and you get [ __ ] I know you and it
hurts you feeling yeah for years like I
said when I was a kid I would do a
walkathon for the American Heart
Association and I always tried to do
something as a kid my mother always you
know I always sold boosters or candies
you know I always did some sometimes I
took a ten I'm not gonna lie to him for
an album but you know I'm saying 90% of
the money went sometimes you know I was
a kid I was a stupid kid but I always
believed in giving back years ago I went
to work for the administration and I
found out there were nonprofit and very
ten dollars you give the kid with the
missing I get fifty eight cents and
meanwhile the two dudes are from the
drive-in 7-series being that it does
something to a guy yeah yeah III I used
to volunteer for a big big nonprofit
that I won't name know but I found out
after working many months and helping
them volunteering that a dime if
everybody gave a dollar a dime went
to to it and the other was to fat cats
living up in a big mansion I was like
you know I was disgusted embarrassed
disgusted listen I don't mind you robbed
me bring a [ __ ] gun [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah bring a [ __ ] gun yeah I'll
give you what I got but if you're gonna
rob me that one I find out now now what
does it do it takes a guy like me that
has our and it deters me from helping
people that really meant you know I
won't give to a homeless [ __ ]
organization but I'll give that guy at
the settlement at 20 yeah I'll give it
right to the [ __ ] guys hand every
time I see this dude I get my twenty at
ten three whatever the [ __ ] is in your
wallet you give the poor guy that I
believe it but I don't want to be a
bother somewhere you know you're in
[ __ ] beliefs hanging out with the
stones and we're all donating to you you
know people are saying I want to give
money to charity what do we do what do
we do and after my experience I heard I
said you know I don't know so Rory's
doctor and I formed the morning James
stand up shout Cancer Fund and 14 people
that were friends of Rory's that have
been around forever or joined in we
hundred percent of the money goes to get
to the charity we have no administration
costs we meet once a month that we don't
there's and we don't pay for anywhere to
go we don't have any office we use my
office or something else no money goes
out anywhere except to where you need to
put it and that is not in some fat cats
pocket when I get out into a windy let
my wife make a donation to st. Dominic's
that's very very good
because you just made my dick hard by
telling me these things that you know
like I said nobody wants to feel yeah
Eddie about donating no you know I give
away shirt every month clean up and I go
up the corner up here and give away
clothes to homeless I go with bags you
know people send t-shirts so every time
Sally since three t-shirt topics one of
their t-shirts let's put on a homeless
person you know exactly I try to help as
much as I can but like anybody else in
America we all work very hard
for our money and before you give it to
somebody wanna make sure they go into
where it's supposed to go I love [ __ ]
cruise yeah
oh well I could go I have that right
yeah no yeah we had on the kid from the
Celtics yeah
ah Chris Herren Chris Herren he has a
foundation rehabs the whole thing we
donate to him once a year you know I'm
looking for places but again you know I
don't do it for attacks where I don't
give a [ __ ] about a tax write-off I do
it because I want to feel good about
myself Goren I don't you know we've done
things like we've paid for different
people's funerals
things like that but we don't really
publicize we don't you don't need to do
that you know the different things that
were medical costs different things
that's if somebody's I mean that's not
what our charity does but on its on
occasions when some of these needs to
help with it we help you're a class act
yeah well making a little place in
heaven for me make sure I put in
purgatory mr. Joe for a couple weeks
with coach and you guys do jumping jacks
with coach and every [ __ ] day oh god
my god this has been uh just weird not
meeting you and knowing you're in the
circle and like everybody [ __ ] knows
you pull them all in to do stuff with us
and they do you know they always put
down every metal of dirty piggy dirty
people whatever you know what having
mental people
Rock people are the most amazing people
that give their time and their talent to
me all the time for this cause and they
are amazing and I every day I thank my
lucky stars of how how happy I am that
these people want to help and still
remember Ronnie and it's it's it that
makes it everything like well let me ask
you something what did you do a couple
of weeks ago I heard was just off the
[ __ ] chain coach and told me that
that was then also the the Dave Grohl
yes yeah that was awful charity oh
absolutely
$47,000 but we raised even more money
because we bid on that right at TJ
Martell so TJ Martell got 65,000 from it
okay then I made it into a charity for
for our charity and so our charity I did
a ticket was a thousand dollar ticket
and the everybody was there and
everything and I raised four to seven
thousand dollars but first n of a shout
and then a friend of mine actually draw
a butler she pleases white yeah she put
two tickets up for City of Hope
auctioned a moth will raise another
7,000 for City of Hope so that money was
spread and made actually that whole
thing made $151,000 not telling about
the event how far oh the event was funny
and told me it was [ __ ] Sherman it
was amazing Dave guy is amazing he is
such an amazing person you know he does
all these charity things of firefighters
and everyone and he'd know he came to
the house with his smoker that was like
3:00 in the morning 2:00 in the morning
but when the [ __ ] morning bro yeah
this temple it was a temperate smoker
then he brought and he smoked all night
or the smoker all night in the morning
he was chopping onions he was doing
everything he was making this amazing
amazing meal he did jump he did I was at
pulled pork tri-tip and rips and ribs
and then I brought some stuff of my
vegan friends cuz I'm vegan friends that
they cook some stuff on there and we had
slim jim was there and he's a butler was
there
Marc Ferrari I was at a whole bunch of
different people they were only lower
than Ron Robinson all these people we
had so much fun and I had so I made it
into a hoedown so we had two
country-western bands
we had a mechanical bull it's just real
fun we we had such a blast it was so
much fun it was amazing and he is such
an incredible person I mean he's he's
just spent so much time doing that and
he just charity stuff for everyone he's
gonna be bowling as well
bro charity it was a barbecue how good
was it and said it was [ __ ] do it
it was delicious it was the best how the
[ __ ] does that guy know how to barbecue
you oh he took lessons and he went away
and actually took lessons on how to
barbecue it's he's very serious about it
really
yeah he's real serious about that weighs
80 pounds I weigh 400 I can't cook dick
makes good [ __ ] barbecue it was so it
was really fun and we raised a lot of
money for a lot of different causes
teacher how much L got sixty five
thousand we got forty seven thousand
sitio seven no less and you don't want
to lose what every 90 days you try to do
sometimes we do lots of different things
whatever we can think up to make money
yeah what other things well we have the
bowl for Ronnie every year we have the
ride for another ride for all these
bicycles on motor safe motorcyclists I'm
Harley Davidson sponsors us from
Glendale no yeah yeah we closed the
street and everything in the bikes we
have about 1500 bikes there dry ride too
and I write on the back to my pink
helmet and we have we write to loss and
seen us the park and then we have bands
play we have food trucks we have beer
wine we have everything we have a really
fun time vendors is a family event so
it's a well that we kick off it's at
11:00 and then the park up is at 12:00
and it finishes at 5:00 in the afternoon
we closed the whole park you know what I
get from you wonder why I fell in love
with you immediately after everything I
heard about it
seven out of ten people who do these
type of charitable things they do them
for different reasons not for the reason
you're doing it for they do it for you
know to stand down the communities you
know these are the same people that tell
you they saved the whales but then they
kick a cat you know cuz I have
especially in the area we live in now
[ __ ] areas full of [ __ ] is this
is this is Fayetteville right here
you know this is something that's a
passion of yours yeah it is I could see
it in your eyes genius Wow yeah when I
hear about your events this is something
that you're very passionate about yeah I
do want it to be cool for people like
you don't I have a funny feeling that
ship [ __ ] sailed you don't give a
[ __ ] if they like Ian back I don't I get
bashed all the time on blabbermouth you
know what I don't care what I say to
those people is go out and do a good
deed for the day instead of sitting in
your parents basement and trashing
people because that's all they like to
do you know it's uh it's really weird
that most people that do it's like I've
always hated it when people have like
things at their house like I don't want
you to know you did something good you
know nothing like if you're gonna post
on Facebook that you donated mm-hmm you
didn't really do nothing good you just
did it to show other people you know
characters what you do when people
aren't watching yeah you know this is I
could tell I could tell we have 14
fabulous board members I mean they're
all passion every one of them its
passion about and then they're all busy
people with like Wieck sales as the
manager of Sayer and the ghosts and
everything he's he's there helping us
we'll get you know Sheila she's busy
with a fitness business we have a Adam
Parsons who manages a black star riders
and Europe I mean they're the people
that we have all the vice presidents and
presidents of all the big sound
companies welcome they don't need to do
this would they do it because you know
what they loved Ronny and they're just
good people they're just good people and
they love it's autumn and Ronnie for
Ronnie's name Ronnie and he was a good
person he was a person that they broke
the mold he loved people he generally
loved his fans and never ever forgot
where he came from and why he had what
he had he's the one who started all this
he started with me in the 80s saying Oh
life's been good we need to give back
something what do we do I want to give
back to a children's charity so he said
go find me something so I found him a
few charities and one of them was
children of the night and he said I like
this one because these kids are like 14
15 years
lots of people give to young children
and these teenagers they forget about
them and they could be my they could be
my audience and we started doing stuff
with children and I and then we started
doing things for animals and aside to
anything autism for all different things
and it was it's it's a great feeling it
is a great feel it's a great feeling to
give back to get back yeah yeah yeah
get back let people know where you
started wave form what you do you know
I'm still tightening but my parents died
of AIDS so those kids took care of me
you know I could see that they have a
little problem sometime I don't say look
they call and I help father as much as I
can and I enjoy exactly never forget
exactly I never forgot I know was taking
advantage you know I've been taking
advantage of people call me and told me
stories and then I find out other things
and now I'm a little bit more cautious
but I always felt in you know just
that's what it's all about yeah my mom
had a numbers book and my mom is motto
if I hit the number 425 them giving away
twelve five she would give it away yeah
give it away just give it away because
you're gonna hit the number again you're
hard to hit in the number again
it's the same thing with life you can't
you can't take it all with you you can't
take it with you no you can't take it
away the most important thing I think
it's people and friends just friends the
most important thing friends family you
know just enjoy in life every day when I
tell people all the time
God took away my gift the family but he
showed me to give to Friendship Bank
which is one of the biggest gifts people
people don't have it oh I have my there
are an episode of friends you could suck
my dick that's not friends friends of
the guy that sitting next day in the
jail cell come on what the [ __ ] that we
do to get it in you know that the guy
that bells yeah well over thirty years
we've been friends we've been through
everything together everything she was a
good lady yeah she's great but they're
all the people on my on my board every
single one of them yes yeah exactly yeah
uh I want to wish you the best
loved Thank You you always have a
platform here I know you just a few
miles from me don't care you wanna come
down and just talk yeah come down and
have fun with us but uh I give you my
word I will donate something today to
the Ronnie foundation especially for the
pins benefit on the 7th do you have like
sure to something that you send out to
people I don't know [ __ ] people like
all like Ronnie James Dio stuff oh yeah
we have we have website yeah yeah sure
it's yeah awesome do some show she gave
me the size I send you a bunch of stuff
you're beautiful yeah let's [ __ ] do
it then like I said I won't see you on
the 7th right but we see you on another
Tony it is a weird date cause my
birthday's on a weird [ __ ] 2020 it's to
2012 easy to remember it's a thirsty
it's a dirty yes my birthday's are gonna
ones day one but [ __ ] day they have a
birthday the [ __ ] has a birthday on a
one day oh yeah 57 year old you know
when you're 12 it's always up Friday as
Sunday rockin and rollin miss do it's a
pleasure and like I said you have a home
here anything I could do for you to host
I'm not gonna be clean I had a good
finger in the air Joker so that's jokes
nice people
thank you so much and I couldn't we
couldn't do this without people like
you're supporting us we're really really
appreciate you know when I called Rudy I
let Rudy know and I think Rudy Oh coming
next week in war he's a doll you know
him and Ronnie were very very right
that's what he was yeah I didn't know he
knew Robbie oh yeah yeah it was in the
bed yeah Rudy was sure I what band it
was India when before White's date he
was in the bed right near the end just
before when he passed away
okay so towards 2012 mm-hmm they were
getting ready to go on our tour together
actually and it never happened there's
Ronnie got sick when did Ronnie get the
iodine most
it was on Friday the 13th of November
209 and he passed away in a 210 May 16th
yep and they were getting ready to go on
a tour it's called the tornado tour
getting ready to go on that tour when we
got the news and I had to call the band
in and tell them what we had again so it
wasn't that bad it was Rudy Rudy Simon
Scott Warren Doug voltage then yeah I
was in the band then yep mm-hmm I left
did that M&E cool about this well had
they put on the album for the tutorial
we hadn't we had something that went out
and I pulled it
it's called tornado it was only out for
like mm I think six days you bald we may
release it but I just it wasn't time for
it to come out right then we were
dealing with everything I didn't think
right it was in the past
I mean we used to call it killing the
dragon we go to Houston every two weeks
and we fly there yet the treatment come
back and we just said we're killing the
dragon we just never ever thought that
ronnie was in the past and he wasn't
that sick three weeks before he passed
away was that the Golden Gods award
getting an award and then it was on the
Friday morning that he told me I don't
feel good I think I need to go to the
hospital and we went to the hospital and
then he passed on this Sunday yeah that
was it was a big shock tough time for
everybody I'm relived never feeling it
Who am I going Jesus Christ I usually
here's somebody passes that was
something that you have to sit down that
night I had to put on having the hell
out of respect them yeah do 22500 my
experiences with Sabbath yeah like I
said - yeah even though I'm a comic
I'm really uh about a failed musician
I'm a musician that never tried I didn't
have the balls to play the [ __ ]
guitar but I used if
things from different places to inspire
me and like I said before I go on stage
I think of Ronnie James D if I go on
stage ten times probably eight times no
[ __ ] flipped me and Philadelphia
you know I hate when people talk about
Bruce Lee
well they say oh he was tough and people
thought my Holly push me wasn't about
that you don't [ __ ] yeah he was about
letting the little guy know he had a
chance yeah yeah he let the little guy
know he had a chance he gave minorities
you know Chinese people will [ __ ] bow
it chapter Bruce weekend-long there's no
more bowing will [ __ ] you up [ __ ] I've
seen Ronnie James Dio showed me the same
kind of courage I never mentioned nobody
else I've never mentioned this story
town buddy until your name started
popping up and I'm like I want to tell
it to a [ __ ] face Ronnie yeah yeah
what impact was on me and I know you
remember how many people wanted the
album to go down in flames but it didn't
it was his live performance you know
every time he took you know I read
something there there about Sebastian
Maniscalco that he didn't do have a TV
show movies he did it one joke at a time
Ronnie did it one song once idiot they
never apologized always thinking about
that yeah let's say that year was a 20
city tour I don't [ __ ] you know I don't
remember the schedule trust me I went
over that was one of those nerds but I
know for a fact that and 20 of those
cities there had to be a hundred of me
those those theatres sat what no space
fourteen twelve thousand Philadelphia
yeah I think it was the spectrum it's
all about the spectrum seventeen
thousand yes there had to be a thousand
people need city that went home I used
to like Ozzy
I guess I gotta had [ __ ] Ronnie to
that wall because the job II did and his
[ __ ] balls that took balls out there
you know and we've savvy I mean beside
the singer from ac/dc I mean people
still go see Alice in Chains people
still go see a journey everybody
complains about leaves a Filipino who
gives a [ __ ] you know he I think he
sounds great
he sounds great but when you see him
it's yeah yes Ronnie didn't have any of
those cliche you know even when Sammy
Hagar joined van Halen huh there was
backlash what Ronnie made that all go
away because he didn't try to beat Ozzy
yeah he was himself and he didn't
apologize I'm here and me and you like
me or you go bring it up he didn't know
brother come on was interviews yeah I
forget what he did an interview for
around that time but I was like this is
a [ __ ] both you [ __ ] interview
mm-hmm but listen November 7 pain is
February twenty nineteen twenty two
twenty two thousand twenty the wolf ten
Peter yep wool trend data yeah and
there'll be more events to come so the
website is one whole thing oh absolutely
[Music]
you got what is it again repeated to
them mm-hmm what is the website again oh
do cancer fun to oak do can't if I don't
know what I want to thank you thank you
well I thank my coach over them the
assistant to the assistant for coming
out here today most importantly I want
to thank you guys any possibility
there's gonna be a tour yeah again yeah
you release those dates yeah released
yeah we're not ready yeah I'm not sure
when but probably later than Mark idly
towards did you do how many dated you
doing the last talk because there's
always gonna be a lot longer than what
it was yeah yeah thing we did 1919 I
thought you did like six or so no we did
nineteen no and then what over people
loved him well first of all there was a
lot of not quite sure without a back
fashioned for people who didn't see it
was saying all the dragging him out of
it grave all these things whatever but
once we went out everybody that saw it
loved it absolutely lovely and we
started packing out the houses back in
them I sold out because we bring it
it's it's a horse show it's Ronnie but
he's not there all the time he comes in
and out then there's a band that he
played with for the last 17 years and
that's day
oh yeah and then we have pictures of
Ronnie behind it's going on is stuff
going on is there's all kinds of things
it's like going to the Simpsons at
Disneyland you got all this stuff going
on behind in this lovely photos of
Ronnie this stuff this Ripper Owens only
Logan sing different songs they sing
stargazer amazing actually together and
then they sing some songs with Ronnie
the three of them sing alongs together
then it's go and they do it with love
the band obviously loved Ronnie and they
do it with love and Ripper was always
Ronnie's protege so you know they're
just an unknown his family so they just
they just have such a good time doing it
and and it's all done for Ronnie I give
it being an amazing woman thank you for
having me man to death to [ __ ] death
the guys don't you still got them out
there oh yeah no it's not I wish there
were more one on my team in the world oh
they're all they're all there buddy you
guys and they jump on a different ship
never not while I'm alive anyway
so thank you so much thank you thank you
I know a great interviewer thing up
we're just talking shitty I wanna say
like an interview at the feeling of
Ronnie was oh I'm sure they did but no
after not after the first show no no no
that was one of his favorite cities it's
still my favorite city
don't forget next week I won't be a pens
because I'll be in Detroit at the Motor
City casino we just sold that and
funnybone Omaha that weekend I think
they still tickets available for Friday
night and then Thanksgiving weekend
the Miami improv [ __ ] Friday two
shows sadly one shows already sold out
to do
you got to do jump on it and that's
tenting that stent
real quick a word from our sponsors real
quick before we get out of here and I'll
let you guys go for the weekend and jump
up and [ __ ] down and get ready for
Diaz against Mazda vow and don't forget
my book you'll be there and we'll be
taking action on the fight we got side
bets we got everything for you on top of
that you got the NFL you got the NBA we
got it all if you're trying to bet the
NFL NBA MMA UFC my bookies got it they
got better incentives and more lines
than any other sports book period
remember what I tell you in the
beginning they just revamped their
website and it's looking tremendous so
go take a look if you haven't already
don't forget about the super contest 105
teams a week against the spread you rack
up points first place on a thousand
guaranteed and you can donate fifty
thousand or one day that's how we
[ __ ] do it here right so do me a
favor church family stop messing around
why pick a win if you don't bet the
[ __ ] thing you play you win you get
paid so today what we're gonna do is
double your first deposit now enter
promo code Church get a hundred percent
bonus on your initial deposit up to a
thousand dollars what does that mean
you're putting two hundred I give you
two hundred all right where you gonna
get that tie back to that no we're
[ __ ] visit my bookie dot Agee today
that's my bookie my bo o ki e dot AG and
don't forget to use promo code Church
you play you win you get paid listen I
want to talk to you about your CBD game
it's slipping everybody in the country
is talking about CBD shouldn't have this
[ __ ] and have that I don't know what it
should have a one should have all I know
is what works for me after I tried CBD
line I reached out to them I tried a
couple different CBD products CBD line
works for me the tension under the
tongue to a nose before you get a bad
night I'd rather it's a doing heroin an
hour later you can't even walk to your
room you're [ __ ] and I sleep solid
I'm 56 I get up to pee no getting up I
sleep solid that's what CBD line does
yesterday I lifted
weights today I went to [ __ ] boxing
and I'm still walking around
that's CBD line go to CBD line look at
that their party test results and you
let me know what you think this is no
[ __ ] 7-eleven CBD all Isis CBD this
is real [ __ ] CBD CBD line calm go on
there right now
whether it's the gummies the tincture
listen those gummy bears the raspberry
strawberry and orange
I can eat [ __ ] those forever and
they're tremendous three or four little
cubes you're off and running go to CBD
line calm right now press em promo code
church and get 20% off your order
delivered right to your crib who does
that for you [ __ ] nobody alright
on it again best supplements in the
business alpha brain if you don't like
it you get a hundred percent money-back
guarantee and they don't want the
product who does that you would do that
one day
CBD no you ever go somewhere oh no don't
want to Chinese food you don't like it
and it gives you the [ __ ] money back
why because they believe in that product
so when you want alpha brain now you got
a little lottery ticket you hold on to
it you entered into the contest if you
win you get the island experience it
runs all the way till January you got
nothing to lose you been sitting that
confused for last month alpha brain is
the way to go plus they got the shrimp
tank the chute export and this shouldn't
take a meal who's better than you nobody
so go to Anna dot-com right now and
press in church boom and get 10% off
your order deliver it right to the crib
alright so I want to thank my bookie
I want to thank on it and I want to
thank CBB line most importantly I want
to thank you mother [ __ ] savages for
always having our back and please
support Wendy do and whatever adventure
she has she's the real [ __ ] bill this
is no scam this is nothing you heard I
don't want to use a loved one a
grandmother a brother has been stricken
by this [ __ ] horrible disease this is
your way to give back a little something
alright guys so go to do do cancer do
kinds of fun dog and give a little
something to help out and maybe next
time
another one of your family members won't
get afflicted by this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] disease I love you [ __ ]
don't forget triki triki watch what they
put in your bag so he got heroin put in
his bag yesterday in New York City who
know [ __ ] we're gonna everyone do it kid
me anyway no I would I got some cocaine
I give them a syringe little bit to
everyone others up anyway I love you
little bastards don't forget Miami Omaha
and Detroit have a great weekend happy
Halloween
see you next weekend stay black
[ __ ] I love you Wendy do